[Music]
no matter what industry you work in
whether you've lost your job are working
from home or have the kind of job where
you can't stay home every Canadian
workplace has felt the effects of koban
19 among the hardest hit are meat
processing plants where outbreaks have
infected hundreds of workers
it was so bad at some of the plants they
had to close meat processing is big
business about 65,000 people work in the
industry in Canada all the facilities
now are back in operation with new
safety measures in place but the virus
has sent a shudder through the industry
it is vulnerable and so is our food
supply is it time for a fundamental
rethink of how its structured heather
Eurex West is looking into that me and
my siblings keep saying that he was the
best I know because he truly was 51 year
old Benito Quesada died from Cova 19 in
hospital on May 7th leaving behind a
wife four children and an empty space
that will never be filled we haven't
touched anything of his his boots are
still there in the entryway toothbrush
his cologne everything still there
Quezada worked at the Cargill
meatpacking plant in High River Alberta
he took a $500 bonus to keep working
after employees started to get sick soon
he was infected too and for weeks he lay
in a hospital ICU
fighting for his life he's always strong
he's gonna protects us and in seeing him
they're super vulnerable I had never
seen him like that
Quesada was the second worker at the
Cargill plant to die of kovat nineteen
sixty seven-year-old hip Bowie passed
away in April the plant closed on April
20th after bouys death
in all at least 943 Cargill employees
tested positive and more than 1500 cases
were linked to the plant it was the
largest outbreak from a single site in
Canada meanwhile there were 661 workers
infected at the jbs beef plant in Brooks
Alberta and one of those workers died
these plants are a perfect place for a
virus to spread they are cold
and most of them are laid out like this
jbs plant in the United States workers
standing elbow to elbow on the cutting
line unlike Cargill the jbs plant in
Alberta was never shut down because of
the outbreak but it did scale down
operations cutting production to just
one shift a day it's now back to running
two shifts of workers but inside it is
far from business as usual that's
because until there's a vaccine both the
company and its workers are very aware
that another outbreak could happen at
any time
so they've introduced PPE so that people
are wearing masks and advisors they've
put plastic barriers between individual
people working in the plant in order to
reduce the flow of air between between
individuals
they've staggered people start and
finish times they've staggered breaks to
reduce the density they've put dividers
in buses and increased the number of
buses so far those measures seem to be
working as of this week there were only
two active cases among workers at
Cargill and jbs and no new outbreaks
have been reported but some workers
still don't feel safe actually I have
friends they still stay in the house now
they said that no I don't want to go
back because we're scared
Remiel NBI tested positive for kovat 19
in late April even though she had no
symptoms
the single mom returned back to work at
jbs last week she says she feels safe
but she knows many of her co-workers
have been reluctant to return for an
industry that was facing a labor
shortage before this pandemic that's a
big problem it's one of the reasons we
have often new immigrants working in
these plants because they're not job
that that everybody wants so even before
the risk of infection through Kovan
which we've now reduced these plants
often had trouble filling jobs as meat
processors inch back towards full
production balancing worker safety and
profitability will become more difficult
but it also may not be possible to keep
workers physically distant in existing
factories that could mean higher meat
prices for Canadians in the short term
but in the long term the Canadian meat
Council says there may be bigger changes
coming when I said to a few few people
in government is what the plants look
like precoded are not what they look
like currently and I don't think that's
what the plants will look like post
Kovac what I do think it has done is
advanced the discussion of whether or
not you would want to look at having
more automation in your plants and I
think on balance most of the plants are
looking at that at some level this might
be a sneak peek at the future at this
pork plant in Denmark machines do much
of the cutting that humans do in North
America Tyson's always been a company
that's been out on the forefront of
innovation just last year u.s. meat
processing giant Tyson Foods opened this
sparkling new facility in Arkansas to
develop new technology automating many
of its production processes
and in 2015 jbs bought scott
technologies a new zealand company that
specializes in robot butchers we
developed the world's first lamb x-ray
primal and this promotional video from
here at the jbs lamb processing plant in
australia shows how the company uses
sophisticated technology like artificial
intelligence to automate some meat
cutting jobs that humans used to do does
that by x-raying
every animal as an individual animal and
identifying where the fourth and fifth
rib are and where that hindquarter cut
is and it's the whole purpose of that
x-ray primal machine x-rays and CT
scanners are used to create a 3d model
of the shape and size of the carcass
before the cutting starts Scott
technologies claims this results in 90%
accuracy the machines are also faster
and over time these robot butchers keep
getting better at their job and unlike
humans they don't get sick or injured
and they don't need breaks or benefits
the technology has already significantly
reduced the number of workers on the
cutting lines Automation could make meat
plants much safer when the next virus
hits it could also mean fewer jobs but
as the Quezada family tries to find
small moments of joy without their
husband and father they're not thinking
about that now my family is devastated
and this time is very hard every day
every day it's very hard they're just
trying to come to terms with the loss
with me from Fort Collins Colorado is
Temple Grandin she's a professor of
animal science at Colorado State
University she's an author inventor
lecturer and designer of livestock
handling facilities all over North
America her thinking process is based
more on visual images than words and her
autism gives her a unique ability to
understand how animals see the world and
her skills have helped meat processors
and slaughterhouses handle animals in a
more humane way and she's a female
trailblazer in a mostly male industry
Temple Grandin thanks for joining us
given what you know about meat
processing plants how many people work
there
how closely they work hundreds of
workers who have become sick with Co bid
19 what grade do you give the industry
for how its responded to the pandemic
well I've actually worked hard to
respond to it
Kovac attacks where people are crammed
together whether it's cruise ships
prisons aircraft carriers any place
where they're together and actually the
the plants seem to be recovering now I
just talked to on two-port plants two
days ago and they tested everybody in
the plant and there were many positives
but the interesting thing is is that
half of those positives had no symptoms
so something's going on here with the
virus but the virus attacks people that
are indoors close together no matter
where it is yeah there's so many
unanswered questions still about how
this virus spreads and how its
transmitted meat-processing I know you
know has changed so much in the last few
decades you've been a part of that it's
also become so centralized in these big
factories that process I think two to
six thousand cattle a day in some cases
as many as twenty thousand pigs a day
have they become too big to be resilient
that's a problem but the problem of big
is fragile is not just meat it's also
the semiconductor industry it's also the
pharmaceutical industry and
semiconductors we rely on three
factories in the world for the heart of
your computer the heart of your phone
pharmaceuticals raw materials coming
from China and India common generic
drugs container ships are now infected
that's like 80% of all our trade big is
fragile now the thing about big is it's
very efficient large meatpacking plant
can do a really good animal welfare it
can do really good food safety but when
it breaks you've got real big problems
in the supply chain biggest fragile it's
very cost effective very economical a
more distributed supply chain will not
get disrupted but it's going to cost
more I don't care if it's meat or
whether it's semiconductors or whether
it's pharmaceuticals just looking
specifically at the meat
industry for a moment though what role
do you think automation should or could
play in the future - I guess eliminate
some of the fragility at least from a
human perspective well some of the jobs
are difficult to automate automation is
easy when you have like a part that
you're making that every one of them is
exactly the same animals have got
biological of variability now biggest
fragile for other reasons - storms
natural disasters war possibly is
another thing that makes biggest fragile
so what do you think you're so good at
analyzing systems what do you think a
possible solution is now is it sort of
breaking down these huge let's look at
meat processing specifically breaking
down these huge processors into smaller
players across the country the way it
used to be well I think what's happening
is what's good is similar to the beer
market you know right here in Fort
Collins where I live we've got the great
big Coors plant but then you have all
these little tiny craft breweries and I
think it's gonna be more local things
like this you will when I first went in
the industry in Arizona we had our two
big ones they would cut a hay in swift's
and then we had a bunch of what I call
medium-sized plants so we had Arizona
beef we had her says Arizona beef might
do 400 Kathlyn a it was not a locker
plant but the to all the other smaller
plants are maybe one-third of the beef
supply now those little plants the
smaller plants have have on they
couldn't compete with the big guys
so what's it happen in other industries
like beer for example is you don't try
to compete with the big guys you do
something that's special so if there are
there are micro breweries now that are
doing very well you're suggesting micro
meat processing well that's actually
some of this is starting to happen in
fact I went to New Zealand two years ago
and they have rather small plants to
call boutique plants and they'll put out
very specific orders a hundred boxes of
some special cut to send to Japan for
example so if we want meat processing
that is both humane as possible for the
animals and safe as possible for the
human workers do you think we're going
to have to prepare to pay more for me
big concentrated supply chains are
fragile the paradox is big is very
efficient big can do a really good job
food safety animal welfare whatever but
it's fragile and if you go to a more
distributed supply chain it's gonna be
less prone to disruption I don't care
what product it is but it's gonna cost
more that's the paradox I don't care
what product it is meat semiconductors
pharmaceuticals pharmaceutical supply
chain the big really big example of big
is fragile just one more question about
the industry I know you're closely
connected to the the meat industry do
you think they have a handle now on the
spread of Co vid 19 and or do you think
we might continue to see outbreaks in
these processing plants I think the
plants have got a handle on it now we're
going to get outbreaks son what's gonna
happen in the restaurants who knows
that's a bigger worry right now then the
plants I think that's gotten under
control there the weekly slaughter rates
are going back up that's a very good
sign that they have a handle on it I'm
looking at my cattle buyers weekly and
they said that the capacity of the
plants they're ramping it up that means
they're getting it under control
they would some of these plants got down
to half capacity you know now the
industry is running about eighty ninety
percent now that's actually good
[Music]